when people are imposing rules it's
really a reflection of them and not the
reality of what skincare products do
it's Michelle of La muffin Beauty
science chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist
and person who is quite
non-confrontational in real life but if
you get me on a rant I will do a rant I
ask for your hot takes and unpopular
opinions about skincare and beauty and
today I'm going to go through a few more
of these the demonization of parabens
was deliberate so products would go bad
faster so people would buy them more
often alright so a bit of background in
case you don't know parabens are
preservatives they've been really
demonized and they were actually one of
the first ingredients to really be
demonized by Clean Beauty before it was
called clean Beauty clean Beauty only
really became a thing around maybe 2016.
before that it was mostly just some
combination of natural beauty or be
careful of ingredients there wasn't
really a nice marketable name for it
there was this widely publicized study
in 2004 that found parabens in breast
cancer tissue and this was all over the
media so the study itself they found the
parabens and breast cancer tissue but
they didn't also look for parabens in
regular breast tissue plus it also found
parabens in the blank samples that
didn't contain any tissue at all so it
didn't really tell you anything except
maybe parabens are so common that they
are in the dishwashing detergent that
Labs use but of course the corrections
and all the subtlety didn't spread as
far as this big scaremongering story and
this is really common with
misinformation it's something that
science communicators who debunk a lot
of misinformation on social media have
to deal with a lot within skin care
we've seen this with things like Benzene
and brief safe sunscreen parabens are
really effective preservatives but it
was too late people were already scared
of it and so these days you see paraben
free even from really non-clean Brands
because consumers will ask about it so
yeah parabens are really effective so
products do tend to go bad faster if
they use less effective preservatives
and I have heard this there carry from
some cosmetic Chemists in the industry
so this is like I guess a legitimate
conspiracy theory but there is a similar
Theory which is much less of conspiracy
and this is much more mainstream opinion
amongst cosmetic chemist not the ones
who promote clean Beauty because yes
there are a bunch of clean cosmetic
chemists and cosmetic scientists it's
pretty accepted that clean Beauty
marketing makes people throw away their
products out of fear and they buy new
ones and then after they try the new
ones and they don't like them they just
end up going back to their old products
so overall there's just more product
going into the bin rather than being
used there's more money being funneled
into the beauty industry consumption is
higher the wheels of capitalism keep
turning we've seen this recently with
not so pretty there were all these tick
tocks of people throwing all their stuff
in the bin fear is just a really
powerful motivator for people to act on
things especially with things like
cancer and potential harm to your unborn
children this sort of fear-based
marketing really Taps into that sort of
reptile brainer vowels that evolve very
early on and it's just a sort of
instinct that we can't deal with very
rationally so yeah true no one's
surprise if you've seen a bit of my
content I do think this is really
unethical marketing also not using
parabens means that a lot of brands are
now using less effective preservatives
which means they need a high
concentration to keep their product free
from bacteria and mold for long enough
using higher concentrations usually
means that you end up with more
irritancy because you've just got more
preservatives in there and preservatives
do tend to be somewhat irritating
because they are meant to kill microbes
also parabens have really low
allergenicity very few people develop
allergies to them and the newer
preservatives that are replacing them do
tend to cause higher rates of allergy
everyone gets Botox secretly and
pretends it's skin care I'm not sure
what they mean by everyone I think we're
celebrities who have skincare lines this
is definitely true in terms of
influences I think it really depends so
personally I've only had Botox in my jaw
once for that jaw slimming effect and it
was really interesting but in the end I
realized it wasn't really worth it for
me I quite like the shape of my face and
a lot of people actually said I looked
worse with the slim jaw I've had some
laser treatments I had a series of picot
treatments last year there were three of
them and I did a video on those I've
also had some chemical peels but I don't
really have any sort of regular
treatment regimen one of the reasons I
don't really go for these sorts of
regular treatments is because getting to
appointments for me is a big issue just
seems like a big chore and I think part
of that is because I do have ADHD so
anything that requires regular
maintenance is just probably not going
to be a great solution for me I've
accepted this as part of who I am so for
example when I got my hair bleached I
made sure I got blend of roots to make
sure I could do everything at home I
wouldn't have to go the hairdresser more
than once every two years this is one of
my big concerns with fillers anything
thing where it's hard to go back and I
have to keep on keeping it up is just
kind of scary to me because I know my
own personality limits Botox is less
scary to me because if you stop doing it
then you just kind of end up back where
you were you just have muscles again but
Botox resistance does worry me a bit so
I guess I'm not really rushing to do it
I do have Micro bladed eyebrows as well
and I don't know maybe I'll do a video
about all my procedures at some point
and what I thought of them but I think
it's also not fair to compare different
people and What treatments they've had
done though there are things like
genetics which means that people age
very differently so everyone has a
different risk and reward ratio I'm sure
if I was in a different position I might
have a different approach if I had a lot
more sun exposure when I was younger for
example if I didn't have this Baby Face
Asian thing going on where it's actually
been kind of annoying because for a lot
of my life people didn't really take me
seriously because I looked too young and
inexperienced maybe if I was in a job
where looking a certain way was really
important then I might be doing more
treatments I guess with this job being
on camera in front of a lot of people it
is and isn't important I kind of don't
want to get too much done as well
because I do feel like it's good to have
people who look their age and don't have
that many treatments done in the public
eye but yeah that attitude might change
in five to ten years who knows people
change I will change but I will be
telling everyone about everything I get
done though because I think it is really
valuable info to have online just
because a product Tony Sarah missed
isn't essential doesn't mean you can't
use it I 100 agree with this different
people want different things out of
their skincare routine and products I
feel quite strongly about this I feel
like we should really treat skin care
more like food some people love food
they need flavors they need variety and
they're willing to go out of their way
and pay a lot more for that on the other
hand some people are happy eating
exactly the same thing every day and
they just see food as a form of fuel and
then at the very extreme you have people
who like drink Soylent I think both
sorts of approaches can be healthy well
maybe not the soil in people I feel like
they're probably missing a whole bunch
of micronutrients that we just haven't
really researched enough so I think
skincare should be the same it's
possible to approach skin care from
either direction and be doing good for
your skin and I think believing either
of these approaches is the correct one
is really imposing a value judgment and
that isn't really supported by any sort
of science there was another opinion
that was related which was I think
people can get nerdy about skin care
slash makeup as a way to make it feel
less vain I think this is the case for
some people and maybe they get judgy and
don't like it when people like the more
frivolous things in skin care like nice
packaging and that whole sensorial
experience of having a pleasant
fragrance and having a nice texture and
I think that just comes from their own
Hang-Ups and also the particular
products named here toner Sarah mist
these are actually reasonably essential
in that these products do usually
contain moisturizing ingredients and so
really it's just Moisturizer in a
different texture like most of the time
I could use a toner instead of a
moisturizer and get the same effect
since I have pretty oily skin yeah I am
a big fan of this there are no real
rules in skin care philosophy and I
think a lot of the time when people are
imposing rules it's really a reflection
of them and not the reality of what
skincare products do every product
should have expiry dates clearly labeled
regardless of shelf life I would like
this I am super forgetful and I have to
try out a lot of products I don't
remember when I open stuff and even
before my blog I was like this I would
just forget when things were opened and
I'd put stuff away and not see it and
then just forget to use it for months or
maybe possibly use but at the same time
I know that the shelf life printed on a
product is not super strict it does
indicate how long something is most
likely to be safe for but at the end of
the day it is just an estimate most
brands work out their shelf life by
using accelerated stability testing and
then they release the product before
leaving that product on the shelf for
the amount of time so a lot of the time
the shelf life is like two or three
years they don't actually keep that at
room temperature for two or three years
whatever it says before releasing the
product well releasing lots and lots of
bottles of that product with that shelf
life attached so accelerated stability
testing is where you heat up the product
and that allows you to sort of estimate
what happens for a longer time at a
lower temperature so for example two
months at 40 degrees is approximately
equivalent to 16 months at 20 degrees
that's all Celsius because I live in a
country that has real numbers the reason
brands do this instead of doing like
real-time testing is because if you do
real-time testing then you have to
develop a product two or three years in
advance which means that you are going
to to miss whatever trend is coming out
the problem with this is that it doesn't
catch everything it mostly just shows
you what happens in terms of texture
changes there are a lot of things that
don't get caught I'm sure you've seen it
on social media when people are
complaining that their product has like
little bits of brown crud at the bottom
after a while if ingredients are
crystallizing out if there's like really
weird texture changes a lot of the time
the accelerator testing has been done
and yeah the real time what happens at
room temperature was just not the same
and it's not like a product is like
Cinderella's Carriage it's not like a
switch happens when the clock ticks over
and the product goes immediately from
great to bad it's usually more of like a
gradual Decay curve for most things so
yeah expiry dates are really just a
guesstimate and so I do tend to use
things a little after the expiry
sometimes if it's like a lower risk
product but I do think having the expiry
date would be really useful for me when
I go and curl my products and I realize
I don't know some something expired
three years ago and I should really let
go of it and stop being such a hoarder
having Perfect Skin won't make you look
30 at 50. this I think is very true your
skin is just one part of what changes as
you age it's sort of like the covering
there's also lots of changes below the
skin things like your muscles change
your bone the fat the distribution of
all that changes as you age and a lot of
this stuff is just too deep for skin
care to go and effect in any sort of
significant way that's why there's all
these deeper treatments like fillers
Botox faceless and yeah other procedural
things to change your look as you get
older and I think most people probably
shouldn't be striving to look that much
younger anyway I personally think it can
be really unhealthy and you can get into
that weird space where you're chasing
the impossible and it takes up a lot of
mental energy and we are in an energy
crisis so maybe that's not so good I
think nice skin does make a big
difference but yeah it is definitely not
everything very very few products show
any measurable results in real life I
guess this depends on which results
we're talking about so yeah if you want
to look 20 when you're 60 that is not
going to happen with skin care but for
something like reduction of wrinkles
like making wrinkles shallower even
simple moisturizing does that by
hydrating your skin it plumps it up and
yeah you end up with less creasing this
is actually a trick that people do in
clinical testing they will test an
active ingredient in a cream versus
nothing instead of an active ingredient
in a cream versus nothing in the cream
which is called a vehicle so if you're
using a vehicle cream then you are truly
testing what the effect of that
particular active is but if you test
your cream against nothing you get much
nicer results because you are testing a
thing that moisturizes versus like dried
out crepey skin because it's just had
cleanser with nothing afterwards and so
yeah you will definitely get a reduction
in wrinkle death plus a little little
bit for whatever your product is
actually doing so this reduction in
wrinkle death is actually a measurable
result that is going to happen with the
vast majority of products that have some
sort of Moisturizer in them or maybe
even just water if you measure it
quickly enough now if we're talking
about permanent changes in the skin then
I would agree there are a lot less
products that will be effective I think
I do tend to look mostly at products
that have a decent chance of working so
my sample is quite biased because I
automatically cut out a lot of stuff
that's on the market as a whole but
there are a lot of active ingredients
that do have decent data to back them up
and a lot of actors are pretty easy to
formulate with so for example it is
pretty hard to mess up like a glycolic
acid chemical exfoliant to the point
where it actually does nothing but there
are also a lot of ingredients and
products on the market that are
massively oversold I've talked about a
bunch of these ingredients where it's
just been hyped up well beyond what the
evidence shows this is going to be a
problem as long as skin skincare isn't
regulated as a drug because drugs
actually have lots of regulations
regarding how well they work whereas
Cosmetics don't and so there's a lot of
marketing involved not that we want skin
care to be regulated as a drug because
there's a lot of other downsides to that
as well but yeah we can't have
everything people would wear sunscreen
more if it was given for free so there
was actually a study done on this so
some scientists put out some
complementary sunscreen dispensers at
the Minnesota State Fair and then
volunteers inconspicuously observe
sunscreen use at four of the stations
over a sampling of days and time so they
just kind of stalked everyone who
touched those dispensers and they did
find that people did use the sunscreen
so it was definitely better than not
having the dispensers there but they did
still find that people didn't use enough
sunscreen and on days where it was
cloudy even though the UV index was
still quite High people used the
sunscreen a lot less so yeah I think
having these free sunscreen dispensers
definitely helps we have them at a lot
of beaches in Australia we also have
paid sunscreen dispenses as well where
you pay like I don't know a dollar and
you get a pretty decent dollop and I
think this is a really good Public
Health investment because the sort of
intense sunburn exposure that you get at
the beach is one of the biggest
contributors to skin cancer but at the
same time I don't know if it's really
about free versus not free I think it is
more of a convenience thing for a lot of
people sunscreen doesn't cost that much
in Australia we have supermarkets that
sell really good sunscreen for about two
dollars I think it's more about having
the sunscreen there at the point where
you realize you forgot to bring your
sunscreen I think a lot of us are just
lazy a lot of the time we don't do
things that are good for us because it
is more effort there is also this other
effect where sometimes people don't
appreciate something that's free so it
might be useful while it's novel but
then they're less invested in it so they
might not use it all the time loss
aversion is usually a more powerful
motivator than games so if we buy a
sunscreen and it's going to expire in a
certain amount time then we are probably
going to use it so it doesn't go to
waste whereas if we got a free sunscreen
we might not actually use it because we
haven't lost anything we got given this
free sunscreen it was a bonus to begin
with we're not losing anything by not
using it so it would be really
interesting to have a study to see what
happens if you give people free tubes of
sunscreen for everyday use versus making
them pay two dollars for it I think if
sunscreens in general were cheaper
although not necessarily free then
people would definitely use it more
there are a lot of people who try to
save on more expensive products and
justify that and this is one of the
reasons why when I do sunscreen reviews
I try to make it clear that the best
sunscreen is one that you can use a lot
of regularly and so that is about
texture but also about budget so I hope
you enjoyed this chatty video let me
know what you think I feel like these
ones weren't very controversial maybe
they were I don't know maybe I'll get
flamed in the comments but yeah if you
have unpopular opinions please leave
them below and I might respond to the
them in a future video like And
subscribe more videos should be popping
up around me if you want to nerd out
more